Es gibt einen neuen mega-spannenden Fund zu
den Ninja: einen 300 Jahre alter Ninja-Eid,
der tatsächlich etwas Licht in die ganze
Sache bringt.
Ninjas, das sind Schwarz gekleidete und gut
ausgebildete Kämpfer aus Japan, die spionierten
und Angriffe verübten.
Die mysteriöse Kunst der Ninjas ist heute
fast ausgestorben und wirklich viel weiß
man nicht über sie.
Was das Dokument alles über die Ninjas verrät,
jetzt bei Clixoom Science - Nur hier gibt
es spannende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen!
Abgesehen von einigen geheimen Lehrtexten
für Ninjas, die wohl ab dem 17.
Jahrhundert entstanden sind, gibt es kaum
verlässliche historische Quellen zum mysteriösen
Leben der sagenumwobenen Kampfkünstler.
Da die meisten Informationen zu den Ninjas
mündlich überliefert worden sind, weiß
die Fachwelt sehr wenig über sie; ganz im
Gegensatz zu den Samurais.
Doch jetzt hat ein japanisches Forschungsteam
einen 300 Jahre alten Eid entdeckt, der insgesamt
sech Versprechen enthält.
Unterschrieben wurde das streng geheime Dokument
von einem Ninja namens Inosuke Kizu.
Der Kämpfer schwört, sein Wissen in jedem
Fall für sich zu behalten und es nie weiterzugeben.
Andernfalls, so hält Kizu in dem Eid fest,
nehme er es zur Strafe mit allen Göttern
von mehr als 60 japanischen Provinzen auf.
Konkret geht es um das Wissen bezüglich der
Spionage- und Sabotagefähigkeiten der Ninjas.
Diese Künste streng geheim zu halten, war
den Kriegern also äußerst wichtig, wie das
aktuelle Dokument jetzt beweist.
Dazu der japanische Forscher, Yoshiki Takao
von einem japanischen Ninja-Forschungszentrum:
“Im Prinzip kann man Ninjas mit Dieben vergleichen:
Sie brachen in fremde Häuser ein.
Der große Unterschied zwischen beiden war
jedoch, dass Ninjas eine Moral hatten und
einen Kodex, an den sie sich hielten“.
In der heutigen Zeit also vielleicht vergleichbar
mit Geheimdiensten, die Informationen sammeln
und sich um die Sicherheit kümmern - Ninjas
also quasi als Staatsbedienstete mit dieser
besonderen Aufgabe.
Zudem dankt Kizu seinem Meister in dem Dokument
dafür, dass dieser ihm die Kunst des Ninjutsu,
also die Ninja-Kunst, beigebracht hat.
In Comics und Filmen werden die Ninjas ja
oft mit einer bestimmten Kampfkunst in Verbindung
gebracht.
Doch die Ninja-Kriegskunst Ninjutsu ist vielmehr
auf Spionage und strategische Angriffe spezialisiert,
Hierbei ging es also vielmehr darum, Informationen
zu sammeln, ohne dabei entdeckt zu werden.
An der Nutzung von Waffen war den Ninjas laut
vieler Experten dagegen nicht wirklich gelegen.
Der jetzt entdeckte Eid gehört zu insgesamt
130 Dokumenten, die Kizus Familie, einst ein
Ninja-Clan nahe Kyoto, der japanischen Mie-Universität
vor kurzem gespendet hatte.
Diese hat das Ziel, das Ninja-Vermächtnis
nachzubilden.
Der Eid wurde wahrscheinlich nach Kizus Tod
an seine Angehörigen geschickt.
Die Experten stießen außerdem auf ein weiteres
höchstspannendes Schriftstück.
Ein Gelöbnis, das beweist, dass die geheime
Bansenshukai aus dem 17.
Jahrhundert tatsächlich genutzt wurde.
Oft wird sie auch als Enzyklopädie der Ninja
bezeichnet, denn sie enthält Strategien und
Taktiken der Kämpfer.
Der Großteil ihres Inhaltes ist allerdings
unbekannt und auch ihre tatsächliche Nutzung
konnte bisher nie bewiesen werden.
Für die Ninja-Forschung ist das also eine
mehr als spektakuläre Entdeckung.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob die Forschungsergebnisse
in neue Ninjafilme einfließen werden oder
ob sie daraufhin produziert werden.
Und jetzt von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge:
Neben Ninjafilmen gibt es ja auch Horrorfilme
im Kino.
Und auf dem Computer kann man Horrogames zocken:
Unbedingt ansehen und anklicken: HORROR GAMES
💀 Die Horror-Psychologie hinter den Psycho-Games
| bei Gerannymo, dem Der Gaming-Psychologe
Den natürlich abonnieren und ansonsten bis
dann, bleibt dran!